sortir ce soir je vous emmène en Avignon
pour le dernier grand spectacle dans la
cour d'honneur c'est Philippe gentil qui
a investi les lieux mythique avec une
création qui ne relève ni de la danse ni
du théâtre ni même de la marionnette qui
est pourtant son dada ce que vous allez
voir s'apparente plutôt au monde de la
magie reportage de Dominique Ponet et
Anne-Marie
Masquin un homme qui dégringole de 23 m
de haut la première image du spectacle
la
voici d'autres aussi Onir et incongru
vont suivre pour sa première création
dans la cour d'honneur Philippe gentil a
choisi de nous entraîner dans un rêve
plutôt
surréaliste c'est très simple c'est tout
le monde est apte à recevoir ce qui se
passe sur scène ce sont des images c'est
on raconte une histoire ou plusieurs
histoire et et ça vole et ça et ça
rentre sous terre et ça ça Ré paraî
c'est minéral c'est animal c'est humain
aussi ces images on ont à la fois
plusieurs sens donc d'un spectateur à
l'autre on a une interprétation
différente ce qui fait que le spectateur
devient en quelque sorte créatif et
prolonge avec son propre univers les
images que qui sont là il y a une sorte
d'interaction entre le spectateur et et
ce qui fait qu'effectivement à
l'intérieur de ça le mot est est très
rare parce que le mot nous ramène
presque à à a une sorte de de de
signification très univoque alors que
l'image au contraire ouvre dans un
espace de de métaphore de poésie qui éta
qui est assez extraordinaire pour les
artistes engagés dans ce spectacle qui
semblent bouleverser les lois de la
logique et de la pesanteur le défi était
de taille c'est un mélange de de joie de
de de trouille de de tout ça parce qu'on
est aussi dans un lieu magnifique c'est
ça aussi on a peur de de rater enfin de
rater cette rencontre de rater la
rencontre avec le public c'est la
rencontre qui qui fait que ça existe ou
pas pour l'instant ça n'existe pas tant
qu'il y a pas le
[Musique]
public la rencontre avec le public elle
aura lieu c'est sûr avec ce spectacle
inclassable qui relève plus de la magie
que de l'art
[Musique]
théâtrale la presse de